so we have a fifth degree polynomial
here p of x and we're asked to do
several things first find the real roots
and let's remind ourselves what roots
are so root is the same thing as a zero
and they're the x values that make the
polynomial equal to zero so the real
roots are the x values where p of x
is equal to zero so the x values that
satisfy this are going to be the roots
or the zeros and we want the real ones
as you'll learn in the future there's
also going to be imaginary roots or
zeros or there might be
then we want to think about how many
times how many times we intercept the
x-axis
well as we'll see however many real
roots we have that's how many times
we're going to intercept how many
however many unique real roots we have
that's however many times we're going to
intercept the x-axis how do i know that
well let's just think about
an arbitrary polynomial here
so those are my axes
this is the x-axis
that's my y-axis
and let me just
graph an arbitrary polynomial here so
let's say it looks like that
well what's going on right over here at
this x value we see based on the graph
of the function that p of x is going to
be equal to zero so that's going to be a
root this is also going to be a root
because at this x value the function is
equal to zero at this x value the
function is equal to zero at this x
value the function is equal zero if
we're on the x axis then the y value is
zero so the function is going to be
equal to zero this is the graph of y
is equal
y is equal to p of x not sorry this p of
x but i'm just drawing some arbitrary p
of x so there's some x value that makes
the function equal to zero well that's
going to be a point at which we are
intercepting the x-axis so we want to
know how many times we're intercepting
the x-axis as we'll see it's going to be
the same number of real roots or the
same number of real zeros we have
and then they want us to figure out the
smallest of those x intercepts and we'll
figure it out for this for this
particular for this particular
polynomial so let me give myself a
little bit more space so let's get to it
so we really want to solve p of x
is equal to 0. so we really want to set
that right over there equal to 0
and solve this so we want to solve
this equation the x values that make
this equal to 0 if i input them into the
function i'm going to get the function
equaling 0.
all right so the first thing that might
jump out at you is that all of these
terms are divisible by x so i like to
factor that out from the get go so we
can rewrite this as x times x to the
x to the fourth power
plus
9 x squared minus 2 x squared
minus 18 is equal to 0. now there's
something else that you might that might
have jumped out of you that actually
just jumped out at me as i was writing
this down is that we have two we had two
third degree terms and after we factored
out an x now we have two second degree
terms now it might be tempting to just
add these two together and actually that
it would be a completely legitimate way
of trying to factor this so that we can
solve this equation
but instead of instead of doing it that
way we might take this as a clue that
maybe they want us to maybe we can
factor by grouping remember factor by
grouping you split up that middle degree
term and see if you can reverse the
distributive property twice so let's see
if we can do that can we group together
these first two terms
and factor something interesting out and
group together these second two terms
then maybe we can factor something out
after that what am i talking about well
this is going to be the same thing as
x
times
well this one actually let me write a
big parenthesis here this one right over
here is the same thing as
i can factor out an x squared so it's
going to be x squared
plus
sorry it's going to be x squared if i
factor out an x squared i'm going to get
an x squared
plus 9
and then over here if i factor out a
let's see negative 2 i don't want to
if i factor out a yep negative 2 i'm
going to get so minus 2
times i'm going to get an x squared
plus 9 again now this is interesting
because this is telling us maybe we can
factor out an x squared plus 9.
so let me factor out an x squared plus 9
from each of these terms and i'm going
to get
i'm going to get
x i'll leave these big green parentheses
here for now if we factor out an x
squared plus 9 it's going to be
x squared plus 9.
times
x squared
x squared minus 2
minus 2 and
i gave myself a little bit too much
space so let me delete that
so let me delete
that right over there and then close the
parentheses
and then close
the parentheses
and i can actually i can even get rid of
those green parentheses now if i want to
optimally make this a little bit simpler
so so far we've been able to factor it
as x times x squared plus 9 times x
squared minus 2. the whole point that
i'm factoring this is if i can find a
product of a bunch of expressions
equaling 0 then i can say well the
product of those expressions are going
to be 0 if one or more of those
expressions are equal to 0 and i can
solve for x
let's see this one's completely factored
if this one is completely factored if
we're thinking about
real roots this one you can view it as a
difference of squares if your view is if
you view 2 as the square root of 2
squared so we can rewrite this as
and of course all of this is equal to 0
let me just write equals equals so we
could write this is equal to x
times
times x squared
plus 9
times
see i can factor this business
into
x
plus the square root of 2 times x minus
the square root of 2. i'm just
recognizing this as a difference of
squares and once again we just want to
solve this whole all of this business
equaling 0.
all of this equaling 0.
so how can this equal zero well any one
of these expressions if i take the
product and if any one of them equals
zero then i'm going to get zero so x
could be equal to zero
x could be equal to zero and that
actually gives us a root when x is equal
to zero this polynomial is equal to 0
and that's pretty easy to verify
let's see can x squared plus 9 equals 0
x squared plus 9 equals 0
well if you subtract 9 from both sides
you get x squared is equal to negative
9. and that's why i said there's no real
solution to this so no real let me write
that no
real
solution
there is there are some imaginary
solutions but no real solutions
now can x plus the square root of two
equal zero
x plus the square root of 2 equals 0.
sure if we subtract square root of 2
from both sides you get x is equal to
the negative square root of 2.
and can x
minus the square root of 2 equals 0 sure
you add square root of two to both sides
you get
x is equal to the square root of two
so there we have it we have figured out
our zeros x could be equal to zero p of
zero is zero
p of negative square root of 2 is 0 and
p of square root of 2 is equal to 0. so
those are our zeros x's their 0s are at
0 negative squares of 2 and positive
squares of 2. and so those are going to
be the three times that we intercept the
x-axis and what is the smallest of those
intercepts well the smallest number here
is negative square root
negative square root of two
and you could tackle it the other way
you could you could you could take this
part right over which part yeah this
part right over here and you could add
those two middle terms and then factor
in a non-grouping way and i encourage
you to do that but just to see that this
makes sense that the zeros really are
the x-intercepts i've i went to wolfram
alpha and i graphed this this polynomial
and this is what i got
so
this is what i got right over here
so whenever if you see a fifth degree
polynomial say well it might it'll have
as many as five real zeros but if it has
some imaginary zeros it won't have five
real zeros instead this one has three
and that's because the imaginary zeros
which we'll talk more about in the
future they come in these conjugate
pairs so if you don't have five real
roots the next possibility is that
you're going to have three real roots
and if you don't have three real roots
the next possibility you're gonna have
one real root so that's an interesting
thing to think about and so here you see
your three
your three real roots
you see your three real roots which
correspond to the x values at which the
function is equal to zero
which is where we have our x intercepts